uh this is Muhammad haib I believe he
what's he saying they're defending he's
defending Muhammad is uh sex with
children and cause pedophilia relative
at all we think that it's just because
we have a different idea of what it
means to be a child which can be tracked
historically on in these countries where
we live in now one is legal and one is
both are one is illegal is this guy
trying to
justify is this what he's trying to do
right now Adam you have to listen to the
end he's not finished once again
petophilia is very relative very
relative and so what are you trying to
do mam you trying to change hold on so
is it not is pedophilia is legally
relative as a matter of fact that's not
my opinion that is a matter of fact as I
mentioned if you go to Germany the age
of consent is 14 years old if you go to
the United Kingdom the age of consent is
16 years old if you go to the United
States in some places the age of consent
is 18 years old in some other places in
the EU it's go back to 14 in Italy in
Spain Etc the 7 European countries EU
countries which the age of consent is 14
I actually mentioned the age 14 if they
had a real problem with it I don't see
them protesting against the German laws
I don't see them protesting against the
Spanish laws I don't see them protesting
against Italian laws the point I'm
saying is this is that it's relative by
virtue of fact and it's not my opinion
that is a fact if you're in England and
you have intercourse with a 13-year-old
Europe or 14-year-old Europe pedopile
and if you go to uh America and you have
intercourse with the same age then
you're not a pedophile so it's relative
based on the arbitrary measures of
policy makers in different parts of the
world that's that is a matter of fact if
they want to reprimand they have to now
come with an argument against so is he
trying to justify sex with children
children that's the whole question
that's the inquiry what is a child that
is the qu the question he's poisoning
the well he is begging the question
which is a fallacy it's called begging
the question fallacy I'm not saying that
their children I don't believe in having
sex with children no I don't believe in
that I've never said that once in my
entire life you never said that once
let's make that clear of course I've
never said that once and I think the low
IQ uh hot noodle eating you know uh
weirdo that was sitting there that maybe
he was sorry to say watching something
maybe that he shouldn't have been
watching before you know eating his pot
noodles eating his Crispy Cream watching
what he shouldn't have been watching in
his mother's sell uh had the audacity to
speak in that manner and try and inquire
in that way without humbling himself and
asking questions and being a real man
which he cannot be and he is not yeah
and the other ones there sitting like
sitting ducks low IQ they don't realize
that actually there was nothing in the
speech of this man that suggested what
this man is suggesting I'm saying if he
was in the United Kingdom I would sue
him for defamation of character now the
reason why I'm not doing that because in
the United States is much more difficult
to do that and it's much more costly and
he's not that significant anyway this
individual who looked like he was a Sho
Sher for Patrick Bet Davis maybe he was
shining some some shoes and stuff like
that and cleaning in the toilets and
then they said just come in for a second
we've run out of guests today come just
say just sit here and just fiddle with
the computer make yourself useful and
give us some coffees and teas as well
and some crispy creams and you know how
to make the pot noodles might as well
make that one as well so this guy who is
a nobody who's you know trying to
challenge me and and pet bet Davis we
spoke to bet Davis me and you and we
spoke you know we had a good
conversation never disrespected the man
myself uh I've only hold him held him to
account in the proper uh and meaningful
way where he has you know over crossed
the boundaries should have had the
Integrity the intellectual Integrity to
stop this uh this Chum from from saying
the stuff that he was saying but he
didn't have that and we don't expect
that from
them let's go on to um couple more Clips
let's go to the next one and guys and
let's just go back because Jesus Christ
you know what I'm saying we're
Christians and and you you have to say
what it is Jesus Christ spread love
spread peace spread all that type of
stuff uh was he a virgin Tom Jesus
Christ yes okay he's treated women great
if we're going to go according to many
Islamic historical sources including the
Hadith collections of the sah alkari and
sah Muslim the prophet Muhammad was
betrothed to Asia when she was 6 years
old and the marriage was consummated
when she was 9 years old I'm just
throwing out facts this guy's name is
Muhammad that's what he's basically
preaching is that this is that type of
uh mindset and I mean we've read this
and we've seen this right all right he
brought up uh Jesus he started off with
uh Jesus um we we can have a lot to say
here what you here the first thing I
will say is that they believe that Jesus
is the author of the Old Testament
because he's part of the trinity because
don't forget they believe that the
Father the Son the Holy Spirit are one
God and therefore it would follow that
he's the author of the Old Testament and
it would also follow therefore that when
Jesus uh the part of the Trinity
mentioned the person of the Trinity
mentioned in Numbers Chapter 3118 that
take the young ones for yourself and
almost all Rabin commentators said that
young ones means prepubescence actually
there is no such equivalent verse in the
Quran there's no such equivalent Hadith
the prophet's sayings there is nothing
in Islam that says you can take the
young ones the prepubescence for
yourself so according to them Jesus
Christ okay he ordered people to
essentially and some commentaries
actually say them sexually assault them
without their will it's to sorry to say
so if you're saying you 1,000% disagree
with it then can you please come online
and tell us that you 1,00% disagree with
the Bible and 1,00% disagree with Jesus
Christ and 1,00% disagree with numbers
31:18 and 1,00% disagree with the
injunctions given
therein I can 1,000% guarantee that this
chump will not do that because he um
does not have the intellectual prowess
or the uh the Integrity he's not
integrous enough to be able to face his
own contradictions and in fact his
argument has collapsed under the weight
of the internal contradictions therein
so I would say to you that the first
thing if you wanted to mention Jesus is
to mention what I've just mentioned and
especially this verse of Numbers Chapter
31:18 you can look go and look into
there there is a website called safam
uh.com which shows you all of the the
commentaries of the Old Testament
especially the the Rabin commentaries
using the Hebrew language a four time
about this the talmudic commentaries the
Babylonian talmud the Palestinian talmud
uh about this particular verse and it's
pretty clear and even some translations
into English talk about young girls it's
pretty clear if you look at the sources
this is talking about the prepubescent
ones so the right-wing people and this
man and other people that want to accuse
the prophet Muhammad wasallam of such
and such and this and that you have to
first deal with this inquire
before you start speaking about Islam
and then now we've already addressed
this but then I'll address it again he
started mentioning about AA you know at
the age of nine etc etc and the response
to this is as follows as we both
mentioned and quite rightly so me and
you and the rest of the Muslim people
and majority of the populations
especially in the west do not condone or
are asking for a change in the age of
consent whether in the UK in the US in
the EU or even in the Muslim countries
we we have no such desire there's not
there's not been one protest movement
one lobby Group by the way there was a
I'm not sure if you know this in the UK
there was in fact a an organization
called piee which is linked to the labor
party which is the party that is in
charge now of government that was
officially politically lobbying for the
reduction of the age of consent yeah so
the only people that actually have that
history are the very people that are in
power in these countries we don't have
uh such a wish or desire to change the
age of consent have having said that
when we make the apologia for example
for the or the argument the polemical
argument that's what we're doing we're
making a historical argument for the age
of AA at 9-year-old and by the way if we
really wanted to say this we could that
someone could say is it possible the
question is to be a Muslim and believe
in the revisionist account of her being
18 for example it's possible it's not an
Article of Faith there is no Tech fear
or excommunication issued therein is
believing that AA being the age of nine
years old an article of Islamic faith is
it one of the five pillars of IM or one
of the five pillars of Islam No it's not
so someone conceivably be a Muslim and
not even believe in that anyway but
putting that to the side I will say this
I do believe in the historical account
of N9 years old and I personally believe
it goes back to Social and societal
Norms I personally believe it's to do
with how people defined adulthood at
that time comparative to how we can we
in most of the world Define it in our
time due to society and someone will say
and this is the counter argument well
didn't you say that your Prophet was a
prophet for all humankind so how comes
he's he's doing this and we you're
saying we shouldn't do it the answer is
the same Prophet that told us this also
told us that Society changes and he told
us all of the rules he told us all of
the rules of how to deal with a changing
Society for example the the principle of
harm the principle of necessity in
Islam these are all hads of the Prophet
that you cannot harm or rescate harm and
I would posture and wager that what you
do with a 13 or 14 or 12 whatever it is
you're old a thousand years ago where
they had a completely different
upbringing and a completely different
social structure is completely different
to what you do with them here where they
are moly coddled and got sent to school
every day and they have a completely
different lived experience and therefore
I would say yes pedophilia it is
relative to one's definition of
adulthood by historical fact by current
legalistic reality and therefore you
don't have a right I would say to accuse
our Prophet Muhammad s Ali wasallam of
such aous crime without taking into
account those relativistic differences
and cultural differ sociological
differences that's how I would
say you mentioned Jesus peace be upon
him who we love and rever is one of the
mightiest Messengers sent at his for his
people at his time and now if you make
that argument that now because he
started off as he's um he's love he's
peace and so if he's one in three in a
trinity he's God so he's putting giving
these orders which you quoted numbers
you know take the little ones for
yourselves exactly wouldn't he also be
the one that dictated that Mary that she
be 12 when she gave birth to Jesus yes
exactly and the the the are many many
reports that indicate that age and just
as as there are many many reports that
indicate Rebecca with three year years
old and you'll find that all over the
Jewish sources but these are things that
they'll just handwave off they don't
care about any of that stuff because
remember now Christianity has become a
thing which you can just pick and choose
from so people metaphorize that which
they don't want all those genocides that
are mentioned in the Old Testament all
those things they don't like they just
metaphorize it they just all those
scientific inaccuracies that bogus
claims of the creation of the universe s
day rest anything they don't like
they'll just metaphorize as a metaphor
and so for them the situation they'll
just handwave off but one thing that
this guy said which I think is also
worthy of mentioning is that he
connected this Hadith of the Prophet
Muhammad wasallam with the behavior of
the groomers in uh the UK now in
sociology okay you need to be able to
prove causation if you want to make a
causative case a cause is something when
you say a
is the reason for B it's the reason a
correlation is different you could say
for example okay that it's getting hot
uh in July but at the same time pumpkin
s pumpkin cells are going going higher
there's no correlation there there's no
causation there's a correlation but
there's no causation but if it's
Halloween time and it's October then you
can make a causative case they say
people are buying pumpkins because of
Halloween now if you're making a
causative case between the religion of
Islam on the one hand and The Grooming
that took place on the other then what
you need as a sociologist as a proper
academic is you need to make a causative
argument to show the link between a and
b and in this case what would be
sufficient or at least something to
speak about is a testimony from these
groomers themselves saying we were
inspired by the Hadith we don't believe
it's Haram we don't believe it's wrong
to take these white girls and to do this
how comes from all of the reports that
I've read read and all of the police
reports and the people that I've
challenged in the last two weeks not one
of them has been able to show one single
report in the United Kingdom of someone
citing religious reasons religious
reasons for the reasons why they've done
that well obviously if they're
non-muslim but if they are Muslim if
they are Asian we don't find one single
report of an individual saying I have
been inspired incentivized or otherwise
motivated by my religion the challenge
therefore would be produce one report
surely you should of all these cases
that took place in Telford in rotheram
in Rochdale and there was over a
thousand white girls that were uh badly
badly abused by these horrible
horrendous horrific monstrous
condemnable abominable individuals not
one of those individuals has been able
to come with a single report saying that
the reason why I did this was because of
my religion how comes the fact that you
have not been able to produce one report
like that means you are disqualified
from being able to make a causative case
the like of which you have tried to make
and that's why there's no bonifide
academic that makes by the way theive
case not one Bonafide sociologist in
peer-review journal journals that make
the causative case because it's too
difficult to make they know that and in
almost all the reports that have been
written by the CSA and the home office
and the Cobain report and this and the
book that she wrote in 2018 Ella Cain in
2018 none of that links The Grooming
Asian grooming gangs Etc to the religion
of Islam so this man is academically
inept he's incapable of reaching that
level of inquiry he's incapable of
making the case he's creating a problem
out of nothing and as I've mentioned if
his issue is of that of men who are over
a certain
age being in sexual relationships with
women that are u under the age of 18 or
even the under under the age of 16 then
you've got 300,000 cases according to
statistics from the from the year 2008
and 20 to 2018 in the United States of
America itself which by the way as we'
mentioned the majority of the states
don't even have age of consent or they
have an age of consent which is below
the age of 18 okay but you have to wor
about why are you worrying about what's
happening in tord and Rochdale and RAM
in these towns by the way if you've been
they're not even cities in the UK where
disenfranchise and poor people are doing
all kinds of mad stuff yeah if you meet
these people you're going to tell me
they're religious they're not religious
people these guys are Thugs and they
were they were giving alcohol and
feeding giving alcohol and giving drugs
to the girls and stuff like Bo alcohol
and drugs now become part of the Islamic
package I don't think so so I I think
that the fact that they're making this
case is is pathetic and it's
embarrassing and it's something which uh
they're only doing because their their
prophet and their true God okay Elon
Musk decided because of his H1B Visa
situation to say such and such a thing
but there will be something coming out
about Elon Musk which will shock the
public which I will be publishing on
Thursday which will shock the public
it's it's the most scandalous thing and
I'm keeping it with me it will
completely shock the British public it
will come out in two days it will shock
the entire public about Elon Musk and I
have the information
and no one else has the information that
I have and I'll be producing this
information in in two days and people
will be shocked to know what happened